Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P Here is a caller who
wants me to rank the soy boys. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Happy New Year's girl. I have a
serious question for you and you
have to answer it truthfully.
Speaker 1: By the way, the nickname there
was Pack Girl for those that not Pacman.
Pack Girl. Very, very impressive.
Speaker 2: Truthfully,
who is the bigger story? Boy of the three.
Okay. You. The fine nail polish piker. Okay,
Destiny. Ah, Answer truthfully. Okay. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Who is the biggest soy boy? Is it me?
All right, this is me. Is it? Hassan Piker, who
wears nail polish, says this collar. Does Hassan
wear nail polish? I don't know. Don't care? Or is
it Stephen? Kenneth Destiny Burnell, the second a
well-known Cuban Cuban-American streamer.
I think the biggest soy boy is definitely
me. I don't know. This is the type of stuff
that the right is concerned with, soy boy and
various insults. And for those who don't know
if I understand the soy boy insult correctly,
it's a right wing insult that takes the idea that
liberals. Is it that liberals don't eat meat or
something or that they like tofu? I'm not even
really sure. And soy becomes emblematic of lack of
strength. Meat is strength. Soy is a cheap, spicy
alternative. I think that that's the whole idea of
soy boy. These people have real problems that I'm
sure that you can tell. We have a fantastic bonus
show for you today. Joe Biden recently questioned
why police always shoot with deadly force. We're
going to talk about that on the bonus show.
We also are seeing more states push for ranked
choice voting in 2023. We will review what is
ranked choice voting, what are its advantages,
what are its disadvantages? Is it possible that we
will get to more widespread ranked choice voting
nationally? Very interesting topic. And lastly,
Republicans are now justifying their latest attack
on Social Security, saying, listen, people want
to work longer. Let's raise the retirement age,
because at the end of the day, it's what people
want. People want to be working longer. Is that
true? But more importantly, is that a valid reason
to justify raising the retirement age? All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show
where you want to make money.
Speaker 1: Let's do it. But he.
Speaker 3: Also makes money to fund themselves as.
Speaker 1: Best. That's right, Alex. Let's go make
money on the bonus show you can sign up at
join Packman dot com you will get instant.
And I really do mean instant access to the bonus
show. You will get the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show every day hours
before we publish them for everybody else,
just by virtue of being a member. And we are days
away from launching the member soundboard. I have
received so many requests from people to make
a soundboard for our members that mimics my
soundboard where I play the clips. Obama. Exactly.
Speaker 3: We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: We have built it.
We are populating it with the clips. Soon
members will have access to my soundboard.
It's a beautiful and exciting thing you
can sign up at Join Packman dot com. I
will see you on today's bonus show or
otherwise right back here tomorrow.